when you're in trouble if you are the
democrats just blame the people who are
in charge of implementing the policy
and when you have a spike in crime in
major cities around the united states
you blame the cops after you attack the
cops which is why they stopped enforcing
the laws against crime so you tell
people on the border
do not enforce the law on the border
then they don't enforce the law on the
border then you tell them you need to
enforce the law on the border then they
start to enforce the law on the border
and when there's blowback you're like
god those people who are enforcing the
law i can't believe those people they're
just terrible so over the last three
days we have seen this myth that has now
taken on
epic proportions that border patrol
agents are going around whipping people
if they're going around actually taking
whips and hitting people with whips
there is no evidence to this
none okay there is not a single piece of
effort number one the border patrol
doesn't have whips
and there's not a single law enforcement
agency in the united states that has
whips because we don't live in the slave
holding south and we also don't live in
like 13th century europe okay nobody
goes around with a whip on their belt
that is not a thing
okay beyond that they have now claimed
that well that even if they weren't
using whips they're using the reins of
their horses as whips okay the evidence
that they've been using the reins of
their horses whips is that there are
pictures of them
with the reigns of their horses which
are long reigns that you actively use in
order to direct a horse i may be no
horseman right i'm in i'm a city jew but
let me just tell you
even i know because i have seen a
western
why
i mean have you have these people never
even seen a western like they use the
reins in order to hit the horse to make
the horse go in a particular direction
you don't have to be some sort of
western expert to understand what the
border patrol agents are doing but if
you take a photo in a particular
position
then it makes it look as though perhaps
these border patrol agents are actively
going around just smacking the hell out
of the migrants who are crossing
illegally
okay all of this has led to a massive
news cycle in which the biden
administration gets to be on the right
side of history you see this is all
about trying to struggle to find a
narrative where they're on the right
side now they say they're not
responsible for their own border patrol
right so remember the border patrol is
run by the administration
i'll also note a bit of a disconnect
here the rule apparently in the bite
administration is if you drone an
innocent family in afghanistan based on
taliban intelligence nobody gets fired
however if somebody takes a photo of you
taking the reins of your horse and
hitting the flank of your horse with the
reins from a particular angle there
might be a full-scale federal
investigation so probably you should
have just chosen to work in dod and
drone a bunch of kids if you've done
that then the bind administration is
like
wow those guys they're doing their job
like droning the kids that was part of
the job description but what was not
part of the job description of being a
border patrol agent is apparently using
the reins to hit your horse on its flank
in a compromising angle this is what we
definitely have to avoid
by the way it is worth noting here that
there are federal charges coming against
haitian illegal aliens for attacking u.s
pilots biting ice agents according to
reports so it's not as though all of the
migrants who are coming into conflict
with border patrol and ice are somehow
all wonderful people who are all not
doing anything to violate the law other
than seeking a better life there's some
people who are actually like attacking
border patrol agents according to the
daily wire haitian illegal immigrants
who are in the process of being removed
from the us after they broke u.s federal
immigration laws allegedly attacked u.s
pilots and several ice agents including
biting at least two agents the
washington examiner reported federal
assault charges will be brought against
two haitian migrants after they bit
federal law enforcement officials on
board a deportation flight when the
plane was taxiing to the runway
so yeah things are going fantastically
well the white house however is in full
scale investigate mode it's time to
based again on a lie basically there was
a picture that was taken again of a
border patrol agent with long reins in
his hand and a migrant who's kind of
beside his horse and people are like
they're whipping the migrants they're
whipping the migrants
what are
okay how about some video there are
cameras there the whole time have we
seen any video so far of them actively
taking
the reigns and smacking migrants with
the reins has any of that video emerged
and we've missed it
okay there was a whole article in usa
today about border patrol agents on
horseback whipping haitian immigrants
and then they had to issue a correction
they said oh the el paso times updated
story to reflect that it's reported had
witnessed at least one border patrol
agent on horseback swing his reigns like
a whip
toward whom
the horse
and what
so the white house is in full-scale
investigation mode because again it is
all about covering ass and if you can
attack border patrol you don't have to
talk about the fact that your policy is
a complete and utter failure or
depending on whether your policy is mass
migration entering the united states a
complete and utter success you just
don't want to tell people about what
your real goals are okay so as i say
there were all of these reports on
twitter
of
border patrol agents whipping people
whipping people so the white house now
says it is seeking more information on
this
so jen saki expressed her outrage at all
of this oh it's just
i'm outraged at all of this okay well
then you might have actually you know
what if solves all this by the way let's
say for for the sake of argument that
there were actual abuses in which border
patrol agents were smacking migrants
with the reins of that they used on the
horse you know what to solve that
i can think of a device that would have
solved this like really it's kind of old
it's kind of an ancient technology
see what you do is you put a brick on
top of another brick then you put like a
crap load of bricks all together
and you put it up like real high
and then you build this brick structure
all along the border you might call it a
wall
right and and maybe
you campaign on that and maybe democrats
then obstruct the building of that and
then they're mad when border patrol
agents have to police the unwalled areas
yeah anyway okay so jensaki uh she she
said that she was very upset about she
says i've seen some of the footage i
don't have the full context i can't
imagine what context would make that
appropriate i don't have additional
details i certainly don't have
additional context i don't think anyone
seeing that footage would think it was
appropriate or acceptable videos taken
by al jazeera and reuters appear to show
law enforcement officers on horseback
using aggressive tactics including
swinging long reigns near migrants who
crossed the us-mexico border near del
rio texas
near migrants they didn't actually hit
them with the reins
they had the reins near the migrants
like in the general vicinity
of the migrants i want to see any of
these people honestly try to enforce the
law and then they're very angry also
because they're videos of border patrol
agents grabbing migrants who are
attempting to get across the board and
then just take off into the interior of
texas so i have a question what do they
think law enforcement actually involves
like seriously what do they think law
enforcement involves do you hand people
a lollipop
what exactly are they supposed to do
when people take off for the interior of
the united states without being
processed in any way i mean honestly
they probably should they should
probably just let people go at this
point since the biden administration
just skipped the middle man and the bond
administration is bringing people to a
processing facility then giving them a
bus ticket to san antonio and being like
be on your way good sir so you could
just if you're the border patrol you
could just be like welcome in enjoy the
this land is your land this land is my
land
in an al jazeera video a law enforcement
officer on horseback is seen swirling
long reigns near a group of migrants
shortly beforehand another individual on
horseback is heard yelling at the
migrant saying you use your women this
is why your country is bleed because you
use your women for this
um so it is unclear what prompted that
why they why they were yelling about
using the women is it possible that
somebody was hiding behind a woman as
they attempted to flee into the interior
because
you might see the outrage there you
might see why that would be unjustified
in any case this this all must be
investigated this is all like the big
issue here is not the tens of thousands
of people descending on the united
states border every single hundreds of
thousands of people over the past few
months millions by the end of the year
none of that is the issue the issue is
the border patrol the people you put in
a position to actually police the border
if you can crap on them then the left
will celebrate you even as you set up
gitmo and even as you ship out some
haitians on flights back to haiti here
is alejandro mayorkas the head of dhs
expressing his outrage over all of this
i was horrified by what i saw
i am going to let the investigation run
its course but the pictures that i
observed
troubled me profoundly
that defies
all of the values that we seek to
instill in our people any mistreatment
or abuse of an individual defies
our values and who we are and what we
stand for
uh who we are and what we stand for is
apparently open borders and crapping on
anyone who attempts to actually enforce
the law now listen if there are abuses
people should be investigated and
prosecuted unless they drone kids in
afghanistan then we give them a medal
but if they are abusive in the sense
that they say a bad thing
or if they
use their reins
on their horses in the general two-mile
vicinity of people who are attempting to
cross the border illegally then
obviously we have to spend our days
talking about how they're using it like
whips
this prompted kamala harris who
i thought was her job to get the border
under control where is she why isn't she
policing the border didn't joe biden put
her in charge of border policy so she's
an abject failure at that like she is at
everything else but she keeps failing
upwards here's kamala harris blasting
border patrol
what i saw depicted about um those
individuals on horseback
treating human beings the way they were
is horrible
and
i fully support what is happening right
now which is a thorough investigation
into exactly what is going on there
but human beings should never be treated
that way
and i'm deeply troubled about it
okay by the way you know border patrol
is going to do they're going to do
exactly what cops everywhere have done
they're basically just going to be like
okay
all right like come on in
because why would you risk being caught
by a photographer swinging your reins at
your horse and there's a migrant nearby
or i'm saying something in politic to
somebody who maybe is using their
a woman or a child to some sort of
shield
you're not gonna be caught doing that
right you're just going to let people go
which is of course what the biden
administration means to do in terms of
policy but at least the democrats are
pleasing their base at least joe biden
is pleasing his base maxine waters who's
just a nut case she says that what we
are witnessing here it's worse than
slavery worse than slavery
what the hell are we doing here
what we witness
takes us back hundreds of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery cowboys
with their reigns again
whipping
black people
haitians
into the water where they're scrambling
and falling down and all they're trying
to do is escape
from violence in their country
okay so i can see a few distinctions one
we're not enslaving any of those people
two all those people are attempting to
enter the united states
okay it turns out that slaves did not
actually want to be in the situation of
slavery now you're saying that haitians
attempted to escape in the united states
who are being
deterred by the border patrol
are the equivalent of slaves
who are being held as property
by
fellow americans
in the most immoral act in american
history so um no on that that's a no on
that well here's the good news if you
just rip on law enforcement you never
actually have to come to grips with the
fact that your your policy just blows
it's just a terrible policy and everyone
knows it and the facts are on the
screens and you can try to cover it up
by spending all of your time talking
about how in favor of human rights you
are well reopening gitmo shipping people
back to haiti and ripping on the border
patrol agents who you have now tasked
with controlling the border that that
can be your policy it's just not a very
good policy
how's this for a title ben shapiro show
subscriber destroys like button with
clicks and logic i'd watch that make it
happen gang